today we're getting scary scientifically
scary when a fear becomes so severe that
it might get in the way of you living
your normal life it becomes known as a
phobia we'd wager to say that almost
everyone watching this video suffers
from at least one of them and given
we'll be covering a staggering 28
phobias today there's a good chance that
statistically one of them is yours but
we're as CP explained not phobias
explained so naturally we're going to be
putting our own spin on the concept of
debilitating Terror at the time of this
video's recording there are well over 6
000 anomalies documented by the SCP
Foundation some are cute and adorable
some are funny some are badass but most
of them are pants soilingly terrifying
that's why today we're running down our
big list of 28 soul-shattering phobias
and giving you the perfect anomaly for
each one it's going to get scary out
here so please don't say we didn't warn
you first we've got agoraphobia the fear
of Open Spaces people with this phobia
often avoid leaving home fearing that
they'll have a panic attack in a wide
open unfamiliar space this is precisely
why anyone suffering from agoraphobia
would hate to have a run-in with
scp-093 the Red Sea object when placed
against a mirror this unassuming little
Talisman can transport you to a
nightmarish world of wide desolate
deserts populated by a craggy faceless
Giants out for your blood with nowhere
safe to seclude yourself away
scp-093's nightmarish Dimension would be
an agoraphobes living nightmare then
there's acrophobia the fear of heights
this is an incredibly common one and if
being high up enough has ever induced
vertigo and made your legs turn to Jello
beneath you then you can probably relate
but hey simply don't go anywhere high up
right nice and easy except scp-3007 a
deadly info Hazard has the terrifying
ability to bring those Heights to you if
you're infected by a CP 3007 you'll have
Ultra immersive hallucinations of
yourself teetering on the huge and
impossibly high up walkways of a City
full of silver spiers and if this makes
you dizzy remember it's not just a dream
if you fall from a great height in your
hallucination you'll die in real life
but maybe you'd take being at the top of
the tower over having to deal with
anything that has eight legs that is if
you have Arachnophobia the fear of
spiders this one is self-explanatory
some people are just debilitatingly
terrified of spiders and they likely
think about it a lot you might even say
they have intrusive arachnid thoughts
like
scp-632 an anomaly that's likely to
scare an arachnophobe to death literally
if you see a tiny pink spider with a
strange pattern on its back it may
already be over for you as the horrors
of scp-632 flood your mind with thoughts
of spiders and your brain matter
literally transforms into a vast
skittering colony of the little beasts
maybe the last anomaly has you wanting
to just get up and fly away or maybe you
suffer from tirumur hannophobia the fear
of flying of course it's nothing to be
ashamed of unless you're enough of a
baller to have a private jet you
probably agree with everyone else that
flying absolutely sucks especially if
the flight you're taking is
scp-787 this cursed plane is filled with
515 human corpses perfectly illustrating
what you fear will happen to you on that
plane but it's also the sight of a wide
variety of terrifying anomalous
happenings from violent sounds to
nightmarish figures roaming the cabin
and who thought flying could possibly
get any worse next we're going to box
you in a little which will absolutely
terrify you if you suffer from
claustrophobia the fear of enclosed
spaces if people with claustrophobia are
confined or locked up they're likely to
experience a full-blown panic attack
that's why they'd utterly despise
scp-1562 also known as the carnivorous
slide this seemingly ordinary tube slide
will cause its victims to be teleported
to a mysterious place in total darkness
so cramped that they can barely move
launched into place by mysterious items
in the tight tunnel around them and if
that wasn't scary enough you're not
alone in this terrible claustrophobic
Place either you don't want to know what
happens after that but maybe it's not
the confinement that scares you in that
scenario but the lack of light if that's
the case you may have nictophobia the
fear of the dark and and if you do
suffer from nyctophobia then you'd
absolutely hate to be stuck in
scp-087 the staircase this place is
filled with a kind of Darkness so
oppressive that it doesn't follow the
laws of physics no matter how powerful
light you bring in it cannot penetrate
the haze as you descend deeper into the
staircase you'll find that your sense of
dread will only increase as you begin to
hear a child crying far below if you're
foolish enough to keep going you may end
up face to face with a certain pale
featureless face though maybe that
entity didn't have nearly enough legs to
scare you perhaps you suffer from
entomophobia the fear of insects there
are honestly more insectosoid scps than
we can even list right now but for the
entomophobia sufferers in our audience
we think the scariest one out there
might be
scp-743 the chocolate fountain sounds
delicious right we hope
because if not you didn't die for much
because anyone who eats the chocolate
from scp-743 is doomed to be eaten by
the millions of flying ant creatures
within you'll die screaming surrounded
by horrific buzzing and feeling a
million tiny legs crawling all over your
body how lovely now picture an ocean a
vast roiling ocean whip to and fro by
nautical winds maybe this comforts you
or maybe it terrifies you because you've
got philosophobia the fear of the sea
this is an incredibly popular fear
because let's be real there are a lot of
really scary things under
terrifying things you'll never forget or
maybe things you'll definitely forget
like scp-3000 and tashisha this
astronomically large eel produces
amnestics which lull its victims into a
false sense of security before devouring
them and hell if the ocean itself is
that terrifying to you maybe being eaten
by a massive eel God would be a reprieve
for you let's get back out of the water
and on to land where all kinds of things
are slithering if that makes you nervous
you might have ophidiophobia the fear of
snakes and if you do you're going to be
mortally terrified of
scp-5430 an Eastern garter snake that
has even greater locomotive abilities
than the average snake because it has 48
legs connected by a thomaturgic means
it's essentially the snake equivalent of
a centipede we don't even have
ovideophobia and that's a pretty
terrifying thought to us but maybe we
need to think bigger or maybe a lot
bigger if that sentiment makes you feel
a little nervous though you may suffer
from megalophobia the fear of large
things there are many large and
terrifying scps in this world but few
are quite as dizzyingly massive as
scp-2317-k also known as the Devourer of
Worlds just how big is this very hungry
boy locked away behind the door to
another world according to our best
estimates it's a little over 200
kilometers tall roughly equivalent to
451 Empire State Building stacked on top
of each other geez that makes us feel a
little dizzy let's stop thinking about
that and instead consider the most
frightening thing of all spooky scary
skeletons skeleophobia the fear of
skeletons and for those afraid of
skeletons
scp-3114 would be an elementally
terrifying entity to encounter this
living skill button actually hates being
a skeleton so much so that if it
encounters a human being who does have
skin it tears the skin off in a jealous
rage and wears it like a costume so if
you do have scalophobia you'd be lucky
to encounter scp-3114 when it's wearing
a tasteful human skin outfit then I'm
sure it wouldn't be terrifying at all
okay okay it's no secret that we
sometimes like to be funny here on SCP
explained much like Dr Bryant we use
humor as a coping mechanism we're happy
to be a little clownish now and then
that wouldn't be so chill for people who
suffer from chlorophobia the fear of
clowns and for those terrified of clowns
we know one show you definitely
shouldn't watch
scp-993 Bobble the clown this Jolly
cartoon nightmare is a clown that loves
to teach kids the tools of his trade
like breaking and entering murder
cannibalism and arson just to name a few
if you're afraid of clowns and you
encounter this show as a kid you'd be
traumatized for Life thankfully though
if you encounter it as an adult you'll
just pass out Spa mercies huh now some
phobias truly can wreck your life they
can make you afraid of something so
common so ubiquitous it makes you wonder
how you can even function one example is
helophobia the fear of the sun however
we'd all be sharing this phobia if
scp-001 when daybreaks came to pass
simply being exposed to the sunlight
would cause you to melt into a deranged
blob however if this ever happened
people suffering from heliophobia may
actually be the most likely people to
survive because they've already spent
their life building strategies to help
them avoid the piercing gaze of the Sun
so maybe keep a heliophobe in your life
just to be safe some phobias are
thankfully a lot easier for you to avoid
take for example coaster phobia the fear
of roller coasters if you have this
problem just don't go on a roller
coaster but especially not
scp-2183 also known ominously as the
ride never ends if you end up on this
ride you'll be hurtling through the sky
screaming in Terror forever not fun for
anyone least of all coaster folks but
maybe roller coasters don't make you
nervous maybe being watched makes you
nervous maybe the idea that there could
be a pair of mysterious eyes boring into
you right now that makes your skin crawl
if this is true you may have
scopatophobia the fear of being stared
at and if you have sculptophobia and
you're not a furry Who's down
ludicrously bad then you'd be terrified
after downloading the Malo app also
known as
scp-1471 if you download the app you'll
be stalked by the skull-faced Mal o
which will stare at you from all your
favorite places that'll get your heart
rate up one way or another I'll say no
more after that hey is it getting hot in
here can you smell smoke can you hear
that strange crackling noise I certainly
hope you don't have pyrophobia the fear
of fire fearing fire is honestly Pretty
Natural given it can burn you to death
especially if you're a liar who's
trapped inside
scp-2128 a terrifying device known as
the Liar's cradle if ever you're locked
inside its deadly furnace you better
choose your words carefully or the
cradle will detect your mistruth and
incinerate you and wouldn't it suck to
be terrified and agonized as you die but
perhaps you don't fear fire you just
fear ladies that are smoking hot that
means you have Kelly uniphobia the fear
of beautiful women yes it is real and if
you suffer from this phobia then you'd
be terrified of
scp-056 also known as a beautiful person
the ideal form of this conceited entity
is the famous actor Scott Johansson so
if you're afraid of beautiful women then
this entity will horrify you to your
core they're just a real jerk too what
if the early 2010s were just an absolute
nightmare for you because there were
zombies everywhere movies TV shows
Halloween costumes zombie walks and more
merchandise than you can shake negan's
baseball bat Lucille at this probably
means you have kinomortophobia the fear
of zombies and if that is the case stay
the hell away from victims of
scp-008 this lethal and contagious
pathogen creates mindless and extremely
aggressive zombies whose only purpose is
to spread their disease to others adding
additional members to their teeming
mindless horde so if that's not your
thing either keep your distance or make
sure you have some scp-500 pills close
to hand next we have another ubiquitous
nightmare Hydrophobia the fear of water
it's everywhere and you literally need
it to survive so it's a bummer to be
petrified by it though at least with
scp-1128 the Aquatic horror you'll have
a very good reason to be afraid of water
after all if you see a picture or get a
comprehensive description of this
massive underwater monster no body of
water is safe from bathtubs to cups to
swimming pools to Puddles the horror
will stalk you relentlessly and Eat You
Alive and now from Big Horrors to tiny
ones microphobia the fear of small
things there's a joke I'd like to make
here but then we wouldn't make any money
on this video anyway for anyone paranoid
about puny perils I bet it's a nightmare
to encounter
scp-165 the creeping hungry Sands of
tool because while it may look like a
pile of sand it's actually a giant pile
of almost microscopic flesh-eating mites
sleep tight oh was that a thundercrack I
just heard I hope nobody here suffers
from astrophobia the fear of storms
though I think we'd all be afraid of
storms if we had a run-in with scp-3280
after the storm this is an extremely
dangerous blob of Living Water which is
able to incorporate even more water into
its mass its favorite hobby is crawling
into your body stealing all your water
then bursting out leaving you dead and
why do storms make it even more
dangerous because it gives the creature
a heavy supply of water and if this
thing ever gets into the water cycle
we're probably all doomed let's move
from existential threats to the threat
of murder most foul and that's foul with
a W we're talking about electoraphobia
the fear of chickens of course the
average chicken probably couldn't kill
you at least not without considerable
prep time but killing you is incredibly
easy for the Abominable chicken human
hybrids known as
scp-3199 humans refuted these horrific
creations of a Mad evolutionary
scientist would strike like fear into
anyone but especially someone
predisposed to fear chicken-like beings
but what if we took a fear of an animal
that could even kill you without any
anomalous influence a phobia like
cynophobia the fear of dogs and that
fear would only be made worse by a
run-in with the ominous
scp-023 also known as black shuck if you
see this terrifying furry Beast then it
means you're going to die soon this is
one dog you really can't call a good boy
but hey we're fair and balanced here at
SCP explained that's why we're also
including allurophobia the fear of cats
and if you are afraid of cats then you
might be one of the few people who
survive a run-in with scp-247 ironically
dubbed a harmless kitten this is a lie
because this innocent looking little cat
is actually a highly aggressive fully
grown tiger that we just happened to
perceive as a q little kitten being
afraid of it despite its adorable
disguise is probably the best way to not
get mauled now let's go from furry to
slimy that's right it's bractrophobia
the fear of amphibians frogs toads newts
if it can Traverse both water and land
you're afraid of it that's why despite
her good-hearted nature you'd probably
have a heart attack if you ran into
scp-811 the swamp woman she's not mean
but she is green and she does excrete
dangerous acidic mucus if you're afraid
of frogs seeing this huge humanoid
frog-like entity would be an excellent
way to ruin your latest pair of tighty
whities maybe you're fine with frogs
though but would absolutely die on the
spot if you were faced with a lizard
that means you've probably got her
betophobia the fear of reptiles the
worst thing you could possibly run into
is extremely obvious here
scp-682 the legendary Infamous hard to
destroy reptile there are some scary
lizards out there but none quite as
scary as this because it hates all life
including you and probably enjoys the
fact that you fear it though for what
it's worth we think being utterly
terrified of running into this reptile
is a very rational fear now for a
slightly more abstract Terror autophobia
the fear of being alone how do you feel
about isolation of being separated from
all your friends and family nobody to
hear you nobody to help you alone
if you can feel your chest tightening at
these words not only do you probably
have autophobia it'd be your absolute
worst nightmare to be trapped in
scp-3001 the red reality where poor Dr
Scranton was forced to spend the rest of
Eternity you're probably beyond the help
of everyone here even reality itself in
other words it's a nasty nasty place to
be no matter what you fear and perhaps
the most irrational real phobia in this
video it's bibliophobia the fear of
books typically books cannot hurt you
unless you get a paper cut or one falls
on you off a shelf there are however
notable exceptions perhaps the most
terrifying of all is scp-140 a cursed
home known as an incomplete Chronicle or
a Chronicle of the DeVos anytime this
book is exposed to human blood it
expands and rewrites itself bringing the
nightmarish David Empire closer to
ruling the world as it is to today in
this and only this very specific
instance bibliophobia is extremely
Justified and there you have it folks
we're sorry for giving you a mild to
moderate case of the heebie-jeebies
which of these phobias apply to you and
do you think there are any other
important ones we missed let us know
down in the comments and of course
remember to subscribe and ring the bell
to turn on notifications or all your
worst nightmares will become reality now
go check out what's the scariest SCP and
25 most frightening scps for more
gateways to a world of Terror